voici le plan Je vais monter sur
scène et je vais danser en distrayant
les filles juste assez longtemps pour que Mack
coure et vole le blé Kelly
Paula J'ai besoin que vous conduisiez tous les deux
Je ne peux pas vous faire courir  ici
parce que tu es enceinte
saule attends juste que tu danses est suffisant
pour distraire toute la sororité Je ne sais pas
pour ça
Natalie ça marchera d'habitude je ne
sais même pas où nous en sommes en ce moment d'accord d'
accord je suis prêt tout  bon non je n'ai pas
l'huile pour bébé
Kokila non quelle est la chose la plus importante
avec l'huile pour bébé vous obtenez comme deux
lignes supplémentaires ici vraiment oui attendez
d'accord allons-y
oh c'est chaud oh c'est vraiment chaud oh ça
brûle boum feu boum  en frottant Shh whoo
oh mon dieu je suis Willie kid partout
reviens au début d'accord arrête ça tu ne vois pas
ce qui se passe c'est ce que
les vieux veulent que nous fassions ils veulent
nous déchirer ils savent que si  nous
étions unis devant
nous ne pouvons pas perdre parce que nous sommes sœurs et
pour la première fois dans mon l  Si j'ai l'impression
d'appartenir en ce moment, c'est tellement
mieux que ce que j'aurais jamais pensé que l'université puisse
être, c'est le plus amusant que j'aie jamais eu et je suis
allé au camp spatial ouais je n'ai pas dormi
depuis une semaine,
je ne veux tout simplement pas  ratez tout
ce que vous êtes tellement amusants, nous ne nous
perdrons jamais je veux dire comment
appelez-vous une maison pleine de femmes unies un
bordel aucun homme une sororité ah ouais je
pense juste à louer cet endroit bébé
que voulez-vous les gars  avec une si grande
maison, nous commençons notre propre sororité en
dehors du système qui peut tout à fait
faire à la fois hmm
comme si des soirées dope-ass et
augmenter totalement la sororité, ils peuvent faire la fête Kappa
nu ce qui ne va pas avec les fêtes de fraternité d'
accord qu'est-ce que je veux dire  nous avons organisé de grandes
fêtes ici proxénètes et houes PDG et
houes d'entreprise Garçons de Boise et de l'Idaho
ils sont comme des super sexes chaque fête
à thème ho je veux dire pas de fromage Oh non oh mon
Dieu mm-hmm
oui ton point